i think i did i think you did too
i did i did i did ah now then
yes and then and then what and then
i had three children and then
and then i turned into a bear
and then yes does it end
does it end or does it just keep i'm in
a loop i'm in a loop
i just keep hitting a button and
generating
story yeah no i hit a loop i hit a snag
there
so that's the end what are you rolling
all right let's do this jake introduce
us wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you have
to have the lyrics written by the ai
yes absolutely titled this like the best
song
about uh janky podcasts okay
written by jake watson here's the best
song about our podcast give it some more
description maybe
you're here here here it's though i need
to ask for the lyrics
yeah yeah
here are the lyrics to the song
about our best podcast okay
and then add some
colon there all right
okay
[Laughter]
wait copy
all right hold on jake here come the
lyrics lyrics coming in you gotta
just gotta read these lyrics as they are
straight from the computer to
[Music]
oh you're gonna love these oh my god
you're gonna love these i can't wait for
this all right this is this is a song
written entirely by ai
for jake here we go
okay watching jake here what's his
expression
bewilderment
[Music]
if i was canadian
i'd be a canada person
i'd have better health care and this hey
i thinks i'd get to keep my guns but it
clearly hasn't been to canada lately
i'd have a place in the world i would be
a citizen
i wouldn't be american if i was canadian
welcome everybody to our canadian
podcast
that's the song i asked it to give us
the yeah the lyrics
to the song about our podcast and pulled
canada out of that somehow
it's written it's written like lyrics
it's like it's blocked out like lyrics
yeah yeah it even blocked yeah that was
it had like phrases and
stanzas in it so disclaimer i'm probably
gonna be crying laughing
multiple yeah this is this is us
this is the most memey freaking podcast
all right so let's give some context
here
yeah so it's been a wild week uh we're
wrapping up this attack on titan video
and a lot of other fun things are
happening in the background which is
i got i got access to the open ai
gpt3 uh ai
uh text generation algorithm that's
i put that in a mouthful words but
basically it it generates text based off
of years and years of
like accumulation of of of text on the
internet so it knows how to write things
really well way better than when we did
the avatar 2 video much better it's very
cohesive
and it actually asks it gives you what
you ask for and it can string together
these huge
stories and rhymes and poems you've been
doing a lot of top 10 lists
but uh it's pretty wild i did like a
little bit of research i dip
my one of my toes into the water on this
and
from what i understand it also can like
generate pictures
and other things like that or is it just
text this is just
just it manipulates text but it can
understand like text patterns so people
have been able to use it to
um uh like do a conversion of like text
to code where you say something like i
want a blue square with red text yeah
for my website it'll like code right
okay
based off of text input and so like it
can recognize movie script formats
and stuff it can recognize lyric formats
for songs
okay so here's here's a little bit more
information on what this
company is it says here's this is from
wikipedia
so sam maybe there's some things that
are correct uh
correct me if i'm wrong open ai is an
artificial it
is an ai research laboratory consisting
of the for-profit corporation open ailp
and its parent company the non-profit
open ai inc
the company is considered a competitor
to deepmind kentuck's research in the
field of ai with the stated goal of
promoting and developing friendly ai in
a way that benefits humanity as a whole
the organization was founded in san
francisco in 2015 by elon musk
sam altman and others uh who pledged
one billion dollars collectively
yep it's kind of intense and also just
before we get any further if
if anything comes up that's a joke or it
seems like it's intense or sensitive
sensitive material i apologize i i
i don't want to lose my beta access to
this
uh and i know one of their policies is
please don't share
the crazy stuff that it says sometimes
because it's referencing the crazy stuff
that
people say yeah yeah just yeah everyone
should know that
it it directly references stuff on the
internet so you know
it's not like they programmed it to talk
about
i'm not going to say his name but you
know world war ii politically correct
world war ii bad one in world war ii
you know but that's kind of what makes
it endearing sometimes
it's kind of like cards against humanity
but it's a computer yeah
all right yeah
i was just thinking about the top 10
lists from yesterday so
let's talk about this for a second so
the the way this thing works is
basically whatever you
start with it tries to auto complete you
know it's like
let's say let's say turn to you jake i'm
like all right here's the first line
and i want you to just make something up
all right it begins like this
this is my essay about george washington
he was the first president of the united
states
many things that people don't know about
george washington is
right and then it just goes what would
you do jake you'd probably
tell me what you would do if that was if
you wanted to keep writing as if you
were just continuing the same thing
oh if i wanted to complete your sentence
yeah
then i'd say uh he was uh
you know uh started as a colonel in the
virginia
uh militia or in the virginia the
continental congress
um i don't know i'm reading about him
right now but obviously i can't recall
these things
enough to sound like i know anything
about it that's pretty good what's the
question
more than i do well real quick i'm just
going to illustrate here so jake fault
you immediately feel into the pattern of
listing some facts about george
washington you did it in the voice of
how i started
you know you understood the context like
okay this kind of sounds like an essay
written by a high school student and i
will continue it in that voice
and that's something that uh gpt three
is doing here
where it doesn't just write it looks at
like how you're writing in the context
of what you're writing and maintains
that theme and that style
which then leads to really great things
when you start doing for example the top
10 gnomes you want to have with you at
all times
yeah i'm trying to give it like these
preposterous
prompts that i like there is no
there's no like a prompt that doesn't
have a right answer
yeah you know something like that and
seeing what it does um
so so i'm curious what if we did like
like onion article headlines right like
yeah
these are the top 10 onion article
headlines
in like the past year like is it smart
enough with context to give us now
parody news headlines how about this
here's here or here's a top 10 article
the top 10 funniest times that
astronauts slipped on banana peels on
the moon
that one's out there but it's gonna give
us something that's
pretty good that was one small step for
man and one whoa
whoa oh he just listed out all the
apollo missions never mind
okay no give me give me onions oh there
we go kneelock 10.
neil armstrong slipped on a banana peel
and fell off the moon in 1969.
he labor said man it's slippery up there
during the apollo 12 mission alan bean
slipped on a banana peel and fell into a
pile of craters
he later said i think i can see my house
from here
i love these like little things craters
on the apollo 14 mission edgar mitchell
slipped on a banana peel and fell into a
canyon
he later said it broke my fall but i
still landed on my butt
[Laughter]
one liner on the apollo 15 mission david
scott
slipped on a banana pill and fell into a
cave he later said i think
i found an entrance to a cave
hold on does it say fell on a cave or
fell
into a cave i i think i found the
entrance to a cave oh the entrance
anyways they're all
so it keeps going and they're all kind
of similar cadence it says on
this apollo mission name i once again i
don't
are these astronauts like actually part
of these missions
i don't know like that's that's the
thing too because it's like
it knows facts like when i type hey uh
sam from corridor digital does this
and then it like actually says weird oh
yeah he does vfx and 3d modeling
and so i'm like uh wow okay yeah to be
fair you have articles written about you
online
i know so it's been trained on that
somehow that that fell into the data set
there
um but these are some these are the
zingers of bananas
let's let's see if this can like it's
okay so yeah let's go back to the onion
here real quick
so let's see if we can do take a job
from real human beings the onion
eliminate a
room full of riders and let's just see
if this can give us good onion headlines
okay basically a great idea just for
like the top like the funniest headlines
from the onion from the onion yeah from
the onion yeah oh
yeah like see if like we can trick gbt3
into here are the
funniest headlines from
and then i'm gonna oops hold on sorry
here are the funniest headlines from the
onion
so i should probably capitalize that so
yeah it recognizes that as like a title
and this is one of the things here is
like if the results aren't quite what we
want sometimes we gotta tweak the
wording a little bit like
the onion is a great parody news like
website well
here are the funniest headlines from the
past year like then
it might give us the right answer
i have to say the whole the whole time
also what what is
also what we learned with um what was
that dungeon
ai ai dungeon
the whole what we learned with ai
dungeon was
as as humans go through the process of
like
formatting questions to get the better
answers
for the ai the ai learns those as well
and gets better at understanding prompts
remember i mean it was crazy to see how
that
that game got better over time yeah
well they also they went from gpt2 to
gbt3 also
oh okay so they're following the same
the same base yeah i mean in fact the ai
dungeon is basically working by
running a gpt-3 text thread like what
we're doing now there we go got it
okay well here we go i wrote the
finished headlines and i had i corrected
it i wrote funniest
news headlines from the onion so
let's read them i'm reading them in real
time hopefully i don't say something bad
burglar on the land breaks into police
station to stay
safe new york state makes it illegal to
mispronounce
wyoming new pope is first jesuit to ever
get the job
a southern california man caught
stealing his own car
rural north carolina man wakes up after
nap finds himself back in bed
newborn baby called quote most beautiful
unquote baby ever born
large tree falls on small boy
ohio couples marriage in jeopardy after
a woman demands sex more often
these are like really weird humor poor
german man finds listening to
opera dull
so but but the thing is these are
headlines absolutely they are like joke
headlines i don't know if it's like a
thing
like i wonder if i would if i if i
replaced the onion with fox news if that
would make a huge difference
try writing a new version that goes the
onion is a
hilarious parody news uh
website here are some of the funniest
headlines from the past year
it's interesting that ai dungeons i
didn't know that they were using the
same
uh like i don't know what you call it
the the the base
yeah gpt3 yeah it was gpg3 not two
it was two initially now it's on three
okay okay yeah i'm just realizing
because
sam read me a story about myself and he
put
matt karen's and then it put me in
australia for some reason
and i was like why am i in australia
talking about dingoes or whatever
and now i'm realizing because of how
it's sourcing from the internet
it thinks it was a city in australia
that it was referencing
okay well so i typed the uh so so it's
kind of like
talking with people here where you set
expectations for a conversation before
it happens a little bit like
you know it's like matt you're a nice
guy so what like
what are you doing this and it's like i
just set you up as a nice guy yeah and
now i'm about to ask you something so
you're getting me in the nice version so
it's like
by saying hey the onion is a hilarious
parody news website here's some of that
stuff it's like
i'm i'm cueing the ai into oh this is a
parody website blah blah blah
so it did it still did the formatting it
even added dates for when the headlines
really
so first one is nihilist sees entire
meaning of life exposed as absolute
[ __ ]
january 29th 2014. wow um
there's a couple weird ones
african-americans tell obama
don't even think about it when he
threatens to move canada may
30th 2014.
obama announces plans to free thousands
of inmates get rid of the ones who just
need to be locked up
oh that's a quote that's a part of the
article uh anyways yeah
as you get it you get it any other good
onion headlines there
quote obama gives congress until july
4th to quote
get its [ __ ] together
they're all obama close
that's funny man well once again this is
what i'm saying it ends the data set and
uh now 26 yeah i don't know obama
oh if this is a it's obama's quote obama
said
when the grandkids ask i'll just say i
fixed the economy
it's crazy to see it typing in real time
that's kind of wild
obama another obama court jeez if rick
santorum wants to be president of the
united states he better learn to speak
english
rick santorum
oh it's getting pretty there's a lot of
f words happening now yeah it's going
off the rails
i got a spicy one okay
look it's so fun i please if you're
listening
don't get don't kick me off this um
[Laughter]
here's a headliner cia director we
should have hired michael bay to make
our torture videos
[Laughter]
what is this that's pretty funny that's
pretty funny
i mean those would be pretty dope it's
worth understanding that this is pulling
from the context of how people have been
writing these jokes
online and just boiling that down to a
pattern that the computer's recognized
obama i've created so many new jobs
even i've lost track
obama we gotta stop doing stupid [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh he's just obamacare so much obama
there
is just all obama obama in case you're
wondering
the answer is no
oh that's his catchphrase it's just
all the headlines are just obama one
these are learner obama one-liners
welcome back to the brand segment of
today's
podcast today's sponsor storyblocks has
been with us for a very long time but
that does not mean i get sick
of telling you guys about them in fact
i've committed all of their talking
points to memory
storyblocks is the one stop shop the
stock solution if you will for creators
and businesses alike now if you watch
this channel you probably dabble
in a little bit of creativity here and
there you know maybe you snap some
photos maybe even cut and edit your own
videos maybe you do vfx the point is
if you are doing any of those things one
thing you're going to want to consider
as a tool
in your toolkit is storyblocks have a
virtually unlimited
library of video audio images
illustrations after effects templates
graphics and more
and through their cost-effective
subscription plans they've got options
for everybody we prefer the unlimited
all-access plan because it gives us
unlimited downloads from storyblocks
with royalty-free
capabilities meaning that we can use
them in commercials we can use them in
youtube videos we can monetize those
youtube videos you know
you can use them all over the place and
you never have to worry about oh can i
use this here can i use this there did i
buy the right license no they make it
super super simple and easy if you're
interested head on over to
storyblocks.com
corridor cast to get started
corridorcast see you later dude
give us the top 10 uh quotes from obama
the top 10 one lineup
the top 10 funniest things barack obama
said while president
here are the top 10 funniest things
barack obama said
while president
all right all right give me some gold
i've been to 57 states i think one left
to go
i can see russia from my house
[Laughter]
remember when he said that if you like
your health care plan you can keep it
uh these are not that funny the onion
versions are way funnier yeah
must be sourcing from a very not funny
oh my god if you got a business you
didn't build that
somebody else made that happen wow
i think when you spread the wealth
around it's good for everybody
okay yeah not very funny ai
boom off the stage
sorry very spicy can you can we do a
story where like
we give it a prompt it gives us like a
paragraph and we just do a little bit of
our own tweaking and then continue
yeah let's tell a story i just throwing
this out there
the mobile version here that i got
loaded on the ipad a little buggy i've
had issues
altering and adding text every once in a
while we can see how far it goes though
okay
if one certain sometimes you do stories
and prompts on this thing
and it goes and it like cruises you get
like
three or four solid cohesive pages that
keep coming back to themes and like keep
circling back on story point it's like
stupidly good uh so we might not even
really need to do too much
but story time once upon a time
sam matt and nico were recording a
podcast with their friend jake who lives
in texas
yeah start there once upon a time nico
and his friends sam and matt were
recording a podcast
with their friend jake who was in
texas period and let's take it a little
you wanna just go from there or take a
little further
uh no we why why why would we
why would we want to do anything see oh
the text thing bugged out sorry we don't
have to make any creative decisions
that's the point
like we don't have to be creative
anymore
is now telling stories better than most
humans
yeah yeah it's pretty wild
it's like it's like the perfect average
it's telling a story with as a perfect
average of the capability of most humans
sure yeah it's like both the good
stories and bad stories have all been
like fed into this thing
sammy's getting the prompt getting the
prompts ready um
should i i should specifically say that
it was
calling in remotely
from texas that might give it a little
more context
once upon a time niko and his friends
sam and matt were recording a podcast
with jake
who was calling in remotely from texas
set the stage jake's audio was not
working properly and eventually they
gave up
the episode was meant to be the first
episode of a new series
called nfof or nico and friends on film
series
in which jake and nico would watch a
film together and then talk about it
however jake went to film school and
moved to texas and the project was
scrapped
wow hold on it's it's
starting friends on film nico and
friends on video
and friends on film friends on film or
nfl for those of you
yeah nico and friends on film episode
one nico and jake watch the lord of the
rings the fellowship of the ring and
talk about it
uh so so that's it it's starting to list
off episodes right now and i need to
yank these because
yeah it's not continuing the story it's
it's reading like someone just
making wikipedia i found something from
like an episode list from wikipedia or
something so it's not like
actually like that's fascinating so this
is where the sculpting comes in this is
our sound so
i just deleted that chunk nico and jake
have a wrestlemania party
yes all right let's see where this one
goes
i'm gonna okay there's a redo button in
this episode they do this oh
see it sounds like you need to give it a
little more context now so it's like
uh one day you sound like you sound like
yeah this episode opens with the trio
discussing how sam got a new job at the
local movie theater
yes it's reading like episode
descriptions now yeah okay for our
podcast
yeah here maybe go back before it gets
to the episode stuff and just like once
i can guide it and be like
you know if this is a story what would
the next
sentence be of like the next paragraph
however jake went to film school moved
to texas and then the project is
scrapped
this project was supposed hold on was
the project
um the project was it was going to be
the project was going to be their big
break
however yeah there you go
okay however that didn't stop them
from their new venture and i don't know
from making
the crazy movie that of their dreams
titled
i i however that could stop them from
their new venture
comma which will be announced soon
let's see them making the movie of their
dreams so they decided to create an
audio version of the film with a new
cast of characters
this is the first audio based episode of
the series with the next episode slated
to be a live-action version of the
episode starring the original cast
the original cast of nfos yeah
this is starting to read like imdb
trivia yeah and i don't know why
probably because there's millions of our
imdb trivia pages that have been put
into this thing
yeah okay each time i refresh it and try
and do this uh
it it it goes off the rails that's too
bad okay
we gotta do the other story great great
setup but it didn't quite pay off and
thus the tragedy of ais it doesn't
always quite take you where you want to
go but yeah
maybe we should talk about let's have
the ai invent the next corridor video
let's just see what it says
quarter digital makes some of the best
viral videos on youtube
all right their best i know i got this
okay sam's got this corridor digital
makes some of the best
videos on youtube period everyone
is excited for the upcoming release of
their next
video titled titled
nico and friends on film it just goes
back
all right here we go let's find out we
can even put in a title and then say
which is about
the first time oh it's going to be epic
oh it's a tiny movie
oh wow okay there we go i refreshed it
they make some of the best videos on
youtube everyone's excited for the
upcoming release of their next video
titled
the second corridor digital video
[Laughter]
so once again it's going into imdb
trivia so plot what's the plot of that
yeah
the video opens up with mr green and mr
white riding next
riding in a taxi to mr black's house
they arrive and walk into the house
the video then cuts to the three of them
sitting around a table in a small room
with just reservoir dogs a tv and a
couch
here we go so they go into a room with a
tv and a couch mr white opens his laptop
and starts
up the video the video starts with mr
black's narration
there's so there it's a video that
they're watching in this video
the video shows mr black sitting in a
dark room with a spotlight on him he
starts to speak
hello everyone my name is mr black and i
am the creator of cord or digital
i created this series you're watching
right now with my friends mr green and
mr white
we have a lot of plans for the series
for example we're going to make
a video this month and then next month
and then next month we are going to make
another video
so it's like a video within a video yeah
just talking about our upcoming videos
there's no actual creative content it's
all these like straightforward like
analytical
and then it just it's just this cast
trivia
thinks we're on freaking imdb or some
crap right now i'm kind of curious about
the cast trivia though
yeah give me some trivia let's get some
guest reviews you know what let's get
some trivia
some some fun facts about sam gorski
that you didn't know oh
fun that are going to blow your mind
about
sam oh man this is gonna get gnarly
some fun facts about sam gorski that
will
blow your mind
i love doing the fake buzzfeed articles
with this thing all right here we go
he's got a bachelor's degree of science
he knows how he sorry
rewind he has a bachelor's of science in
computer science from michigan state
university
he also has a master's of science in
computer science from the university of
michigan he's been a programmer
programmer for over 24 years
and he's been a software architect for
16 years wow
all that and he's also a musician who
plays bass guitar in a band called
bruiser
writer who has published six books he's
also a husband father of three
how to stay in touch with sam visit
samgorsky.com to learn more about sam
and his books
sam's van let's keep going what are the
favorite songs from the band bruce no
no it's it's it did the end text of a
website with like follow him
you can follow him on twitter at sam
gorsey
you can also email him at sam
samgorski.com
take me into the bruiser like top hits
best yeah the biggest hits from the band
bruiser
yeah yeah the lyrics to bruiser's number
one song
samurai there you go
okay so all that and he's a musician who
plays bass guitar in a band called
bruiser
because you need to keep this other text
at the top so i'm going to say that
bruisers
uh how do i go for that top song
had lyrics that go like this uh
one day or the idea for the lyrics for
uh their number one hit uh k
uh are i mean you can just do that or
like came into sam's mind when he was
watching
a train roll down the lyrics for their
number one hit
are i'm just gonna say that okay
all the things you say you gotta do the
things you say you've got to do today
turn them into a punch card
check it out through your card reader
save those things you want to do save
those things you want to see
your web pressing history
oh my god uh i cannot i cannot read what
it says after that
it's too saucy turn them into a pie for
the internet
no i deleted it
if you get stuck you can ask me for help
i will help you to get on stuff
if you save enough money then you won't
have to work you can spend all your time
doing the things you want to do
oh the hit song
skyrocketed wait hold on can you ask
what the title is of the song
what's the title of this okay i'm just
gonna write
those are the it's the classic bruiser
song punch card those
are the lyrics
to their hit song
comma title oh
oh it's a lot of text
did you put titles in there no no no no
it didn't work didn't work
doesn't go on the rails we're going back
to sandbags
computers it's like it's so hard to like
direct it down like a package no no it's
after the lyrics it doesn't know what to
do after that
what did you just have inside like what
does this mean like what does this even
mean
like i know that song lyrics are
meaningless
so i'm like yeah right well let's let's
write another song let's be like
maybe at the top like like what is the
history of the band bruiser can we dig
into that
well do you want it in the context of
sam yeah definitely yeah so that means
i'm gonna have to go up and
delete the lyrics okay so he's in a band
called bruiser
we've already established i'm a computer
guy bruiser is a multi-platinum
band crews are known for their four
yeah best known for and just let's see
what it comes up with oh there we go
okay multi
hyphen platinum band
known for
bruiser is a multi-platinum band known
for its high-energy live shows
and sam plays in the band whenever he
can
[Laughter]
greatest hits i'm gonna add that it it
predicted a completion so
all right bruisers
greatest so this is taking on the
cadence of a news article
our
bruiser's greatest hits are
no no try again brutus
bruiser's latest album is called tangled
in the pines
and is available on amazon
oh it just went back to crazier sound
facts now
oh no there we go bruiser's i refresh it
again you have to sometimes prod it
greatest hits are somebody's watching
cowards
time to move on lonely at the top see
you in hell standing in line i'm here
the slow ride on my way
sam's other band
is called tweek brothers
their greatest hits are idiots i'm a
jerk i want to be a rock star
the last day wake up the way i am [ __ ]
this [ __ ] fight this [ __ ]
am i what am i i want to be i don't want
to be i am
uh also i've been a professor at oakland
university since 2010.
that's the name of one of the songs dude
i want to hear i want to hear the lyrics
one of those songs
all right uh which uh punk my might
which band
tweeker tweaker brothers tweeker
brothers tweak brothers
all right i like how it just thinks that
you have these
brothers now we got the tweaker brothers
yeah
oh oh oh oh i feel like most ais like
kind of just like sputter out and like
weave off into nothing whereas this one
like it starts to like sputter out and
then immediately just plants his foot
and goes like fine
here's another band and here's the name
and here's the songs
and you're like wow
you didn't like the first one he's got
another yeah
he plays with him whenever he can yeah
all right let's find out uh sorry it's
taking a minute to delete just
janky mobile interface sam sam plays in
the band bruiser
whenever he can usually whenever they're
on tour
with his main band tweaker brothers the
old tweaker brothers man
he underwrote his famous lyrics oh
what oh i it wiped it wiped we're at the
top
oh well yeah oh man well
you'll never know what the tweak
brothers lyrics were about
we'll always have the memories of the
twigger brothers let's take this let's
just dude we can invent anything right
now we can
invent anything who wants to he wants to
he wants the laser i can shoot the laser
down yeah
here i i can throw a million ideas i
just i can't stop it's just
gonna keep coming out of it all right
let's do it um
this many people don't know that aliens
have visited us before
if you look closely you can see evidence
all around you in particular
aliens have been on
our planet for years
this is going to be a good one if you
look around closely
comma you'll find that okay
many people don't know that aliens have
been on our planet for years
if you look around closely you'll find
that aliens have been in movies
commercials music videos and even news
reports for years
i don't believe they're here to invade
us or cause any harm but i do believe
they've been observing us for years
because they're interested in us as a
species
you're probably wondering how aliens are
going to help you get a job
well they're not aliens aren't going to
help you get the job however aliens
have all been in them have however
aliens have been in all the movies that
you've seen so you can learn
from their examples
[Laughter]
all the movies all of them so you can
learn from their intelligence and logic
hold on it's going into some like weird
like job interview crap
if you study aliens you'll notice they
have a certain way of interacting
with people that works first they're not
overly polite
they're not overly pushy they're not
overly bossy however they are confident
[Laughter]
into like the qualities of like being
assertive yeah it's about aliens you've
probably seen a lot of movies where
aliens are portrayed as maniacal
creatures bent on ruling the world and
killing us all
you can learn a lot from their example
these aliens are bent on killing us all
but they still go around in groups
they're not worried about other aliens
killing them because they trust each
other they know what their purpose is
and they work together
so that's why you need to learn how to
work together as a team
of petty arguments or to worry about
what other people are doing you need to
worry about how you're doing
and if you're not working together as a
team you won't get the job
it keeps like blending aliens and like a
job interview
i got one can we ask it what the most
common jobs are
seen on an alien resume okay nice
that's a that's a good one
here are the top 10 jobs you'll see on
an
alien's resume
all right
um i'm getting game of thrones character
names
[Laughter]
it's a little off supreme being messiah
alien the devil jesus angel of death
father of lies lord of the flies
it's not i i i want it seamstress
cook welders regular jobs
they gotta have you know they gotta get
no i'm starting to get some weird ones
here we go
a ufo knot a person who's very
comfortable around extra
terrestrials and who travels to visit
them in our skies
a ufologist a person who studies ufo
phenomenon and collects research
data a telepath a person who's able to
telepathically
communicate with aliens interplanetary
agent a person who is sent to earth from
another planet to help us evolve
alien abductee a person abducted by
aliens
alien greeter a person who greets
extraterrestrials
when they land and escorts them
throughout earth
2015 to 2019 alien greeter
[Laughter]
my job was to greet aliens we came to
earth
you might be wondering what are some of
the other job titles you might see on a
resume for a space alien
well here are the top 10 jobs you'll see
on an alien's resume that weren't on
that list
one galactic president a person who's
the president
of their own galaxy but is still a
citizen of their home planet
two galactic god a person who's
worshiped by many people some of whom
are citizens of their home planet
three a star fighter a person who fights
in space battles with spaceships oh
great
four space pirates alien jobs
and takes their valuables five space
avenger a person who patrols space to
protect it from enemies
space explorer space pilot space captain
space navigator
space traveler oh but it just looped but
that that was actually the first loop
that gave me something better
yeah so it just said if you're wondering
what are some of the other
job titles you might see for a space
alien that aren't on on this list well
here are some of the top 10 jobs here we
go ah oh
ah now it's a full loop it's a full loop
we got
with a little digging you know a little
little sifting through it we got some
great alien jobs yeah yeah
i got i got one for you i got a story
for you you have a story all right
it's a story maybe a film uh two
producers
two broadway producers can you text the
speeches can you say
yeah yeah uh okay so it's way easier
than me typing it yeah
all right you get you have basically one
shot at saying it
can i just yeah
just use the mic press the microphone
you're good to go
this one the mic the microphone icon
near the keyboard oh yeah i got you
let me think about this okay
two broadway producers want to adapt
a musical based on the film snakes on a
plane
okay just hit the mic again oh two
okay all right
all right better lin manuel miranda
better be in this
yeah going for that producer's vibe
come on i'm going to play an interlude
song there we go you better because this
this mobile interface is stinking
i can't delete your too typo
[Music]
should be in the app just elevator music
had to give me the lyrics for the
interlude
is she gonna if he got a problem are
they adapting into a musical
and do a musical yeah snakes on a plane
the musical right two broadway producers
are going to adapt the movie snakes on a
plane into the musical into a musical
comma
stage the musical
two i'm gonna even give them names two
broadway producers matt and nico
oh
how long have you been producing
broadway boys big broadway first
two broadway producers matt and nico are
going to adapt the movie snakes on a
plane into a musical
titled snakes on a stage the producers
have already talked to director david r
ellis about it
ella says we already have rights to the
title i'd be i'd be happy to give you
the rights to the idea if they want to
develop it
the producers will have to show um how a
musical adaptation of a movie could work
i hear the producers are working on a
script now i don't know if they've
talked to the writers of snakes on a
planet
the producers will have to find a way to
keep the public interested
in a musical about a plane full of
snakes
back to this director there's a lot of
snakes on a plane and there's a lot of
planes to crash cydos
there's a lot of those two things the
producers are hoping that to bring
everything they can from the movie to
the stage
oh here we go matt starts talking oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
we're hoping to get the snakes on stage
said matt
we're hoping to get some of the actors
from the movie to come out and do some
of the songs
david jackson if the idea if the idea of
a musical about snakes on a plane
doesn't work the producers have a
back-up plan
oh okay matt's matt another cool line
from matt
and i'm gonna before i read it i'm gonna
give it a little extra bonus
inspiration inspiration point
inspiration
dude i love it this isn't i'm working on
a musical
about the hangover said matt let me tell
you more
we're going to go into the jungle with a
bunch of guys we're going to get them
wasted as [ __ ]
and they're going to wake up wake up
with a bunch of girls
the producers want to bring the movie
from the screen to the stage with a
musical
yes uh it's this is a news article
[Laughter]
wait but what's the what's going to be
the hit song from uh yeah the hangover
musical slash stage
the hit song from the hangover musical
slash
snakes on a plane okay it's a double
feature
broadway i need to i need to add that
prompt one second the producers are also
are also very
excited to have
landed the rights
to the hit song
all right what hit song is it going to
be how about uh
i've got a plane to catch oh nice
matt it's okay matt they keep coming
today they love me matt matt says
i don't think anyone else has that song
says matt it's a pretty good song
the music the producers don't have any
estimate of when the musical is expected
to be finished
we're not going to rush it says nico we
want it to be good
yeah matt chimes i mean we're going to
wait until the script is good and the
songs are good
the producers have our producers have
already talked to the director of the
show jeff calhoun
oh calhoun we want to make sure it's
real good we're not going to rush it
either
it's going to be awesome says nico do
you want to hear some what the song
sounds like
yeah what is
we want to make sure it's a good show i
got a plane to catch it's a pretty good
song and it's
not in the movie if the musical snakes
on stage is successful the producers
are going to try and do an adaptation of
the hangover oh yeah we already talked
about that
we're going to try and do the same thing
matt's coming in we try and do the same
thing
we did with that musical we're going to
put it on the stage hold on
it's just a formula guys
[Music]
y'all ever seen project x we're putting
it on the stage oh man the
producers have given
us a sneak
peek at the lyrics
to i've got a plane to catch i've got a
plane to catch
i've got a pain to catch running through
the terminal
half hour late will it leave
right here let's see here we go oh
i've got a plane to catch i got a plane
to catch i think i've got a plane to
catch
but i don't know where it's at and no
one can tell me where it's at so nobody
can tear it sweat i'll be a son of a gun
if i miss this plane
i'm gonna be pissed but if i miss this
plane i'm gonna be dead
i got a plane to catch it
i think i got a plane the catch and i
don't know where it is at
and nobody can tell me where it's at
nobody can tell me where
nobody's
and for those who don't know what snakes
on a plane is about here's a quick
refresher
[Applause]
yes snakes on a plane is about well you
guessed it a snake's on a plane
it's about a plane full of snakes that
are trying to kill a witness in a trial
against a well-known drug lord samuel l
jackson plays the main character
named of course samuel
[Music]
oh man that's incredible really it's
like
it's kind of got like a sense of humor
yeah it's just pulling from
the humor of the internet i think it's
all our humor man
like it's just it's like it's it's the
pure absurdity of what we know a normal
article is supposed to say or like
like the ridiculousness of like painting
one of us in this
like absurd light of fake facts
yeah you know i i just can you just do
the prompt the best joke in the world
yeah what is the best joke top 10 best
jokes in the world there could only be
one i'm just gonna write
i'm just i just typed the best joke in
the world enter
is that he was a man of peace
hold on uh is that oh can't say that one
that one that one is that one has you
know who in it
why does it always go back there on the
first day of school the teacher tells a
joke to all of the students
why did the chicken cross the road the
students
think about it but can't answer it's
obvious said the teacher to get to the
other side
[Laughter]
here here all right the best joke in the
world is to tell
um i'm not gonna say this
i'm not gonna say that let's do uh let's
the best joke in the world is not a joke
at all
it's the truth and it's even funnier
it's if it's the truth right on
sorry that's a little philosophy for you
there
uh it's not really giving us the best
joke okay
okay here i gotta wait can we give me a
week oh oh sorry as i said give me a
motivational speech
yeah okay i'll give you motivational
speech like before battle
nico is a motivational speaker
who goes to battle zones
to with timber the soldiers
period below
is one of his most famous inspirational
battle speeches
period yes
niko's always dreamed of this dude i
love this it's quite long
it's worth watching the whole thing
hold on watching ladies and gentlemen of
the armed forces you have just fallen
too to be part of a small group of men
and women that will make up the greatest
fighting force in the history of mankind
when you came here today you came here
to be the best now
i don't know if you're going to be the
best but i'm going to make damn sure
that you will be the toughest
you'll be the most physically fit you'll
be the most mentally disciplined you'll
be the most tactically proficient
you'll be the most technically
proficient and you will be the baddest
[ __ ] of the air
and it's my job to make you that i don't
know what kind of civilian
lives you had before you came here but
those lives are over you're a warrior
now you're a celtic in the united states
army
and every single one of you was
volunteered to be a part of something
special
something different something
extraordinary
you volunteered to be part of something
that is going
to change the world
this is not your last fight this is also
not your first fight
this is not even your fight
because the way i see it everyone who is
single one of you is representative of
the united states army
the representative of the american
people you're representative every
single man and woman who's ever fought
for
this country and everyone who's ever
died for it and because of that i'm
going to make you the best damn soldier
you can possibly be
you're gonna be the ones who fight this
war and win it for us
wait why is this actually a good speech
when you get it
once you get out of this place you're
going to become a weapon
that's going to protect the things you
love your family your friends your
country and most importantly
your freedom and before you go let me
tell you what freedom is
oh yes oh yes freedom is waking up
tomorrow morning
in your bed in your room it's your wife
your husband your children your family
your home your friends it's your school
knowing that you got up today
and you're going to live to see another
day that's what freedom is
it's being to live to see another day
now the only way you're going to be able
to do that is if you go out there
and you're going to be willing to fight
for it
you got to be willing to sacrifice for
it you have to be willing
to die for it and the only way that you
know you're willing to die for it
is for you to know what you're dying for
so i'm going to make you that soldier
as i said before i'm repeating this now
i'm going to make you the baddest
[ __ ] who has ever lived
and when i'm done with you you're going
to stay that way
you're going to be the same way now
and he i can keep going he just doesn't
end up
this is pretty [ __ ] inspirational
yeah did it say that it was repeating
itself
no i said that added that because it
said baddest [ __ ]
mute
[Laughter]
all right can we have it give us the
plot for like the next say like
avengers movie oh yeah spoiler alert
everybody let's do something a little
bit more
let's do something a little bit more uh
like buttoned down
what about like the most famous last
words
oh yeah in a movie or yeah what about in
general
history top 10 famous lessons
all right here we go top 10
most famous last words
it might just give us individual words
hopefully not
um that's not last words
uh that one's kind of long and not very
funny uh i'm gonna try one more
refresh okay
uh maybe top 10 famous last words
instead of most famous last words
oh there we go i got some i got some
there we go
quote revenge is sweet but not fattening
william frederick cody 1846
another one we are all worms but i do
believe i am a glow worm
western churchill
okay i forget he would say i forgive
alfred dreyfuss emil zola 1840
i'm bored what an awful thing to say
oscar wilde
1854 i am ready my god i am ready
gandhi
i am going to make him an offer he can't
refuse
vito corleone just put a cabin over here
oh my god
i did not think i'd take a ride with the
lord jesus christ
james joyce oh so you and hillary boys
jesse james i'm ready to meet my maker
whether my maker is prepared for the
great ordeal of meeting me is another
matter
winston churchill i'd rather be fishing
nixon
oh my god oh no i am ready
jesus christ
[Laughter]
oh no
oh it just lists all the punic wars
it's just the pewdiepie i don't even
know what the [ __ ] is it
what a pivot
okay
[Laughter]
there's so many tears coming out of my
eyes right now
so dumb god it is it's really stupid
with the historical figures
narrative what do you mean pretty funny
what are we talking about
like famous quotes from historical
figures
funniest give me give me the like
something i didn't something you didn't
know about abraham lincoln is
yeah one thing you didn't know about
abraham lincoln
is that oh no
he always spoiled a beard oh that didn't
go down well with his wife mary todd
lincoln who nagged him to shave it on
many occasions you can't blame her
really
her husband is not exactly the most
handsome man
wow let's try it again um
he was the master of all trades nah man
let's see some more stories about us
like let's give a
wife a lunatic situation
that did happen these are just fake
facts oh fake
he was a very big fan of professional
wrestling which he watched with his wife
considering his beloved status in
america it's not surprising he'd be
such a fan of a sport so
quintessentially american
yeah okay give me the top
uh give me like the top top 10 reasons
to be friends with jake watson
here we go here are the top 10 reasons
to be friends
with jake watson
ah darn it glitched one more time
here are the top 10 reasons to be
friends with jake watson
only the top ten
one he's the most awesome guy you'll
ever meet um
two he's handsome three he's great at
sports
four he's the best friend you'll ever
have five he's nice to everybody
six he's smart but doesn't show it off
seven he's funny eight he's a good
dancer
nine he's freaking amazing that's all i
can say
he's the best boyfriend you could ever
have bye love you your girlfriend sarah
p.s he's 13.
it goes into uh um something it found in
like a hot singles in your area kind of
vibe uh giving you the top 10
facts about matt or why you want matt to
be your friend what's the most what's
the
most embarrassing thing matt carren's
has ever done oh yeah there you go i'm
going to tell you
about the most embarrassing thing
oops i tried one time i'm going to tell
you about the most
embarrassing thing why is it not working
one more time i'm going to tell you
about the most
embarrassing thing that matt
i think it's confusing with you
confusing you with a new zealand
person oh that's that's great that
sounds great
because i did your name earlier maybe
associated with chord or digital by
saying
matt matt karen's of court or digital oh
boy
yeah no
it was a few years it was a few years
ago and matt was in his late 30s he was
in a really bad place
[Laughter]
very mentally times drinking too much
started taking drugs again he was
depressed suicidal
he overdosed on okay
so it was 2005. i was in l.a for a few
days and i met a girl there a model she
lived there pretty
a model i got her number and then for
the next two or three years we started
texting each other
i'd go to the states every few weeks and
always called her
what hold on this is not about matt no
it's not
it's also in the first person hold on
it's just this love story with this in
this like
i i'm i'm a little confused if it's
putting you in australia then it's
probably thinking
that one's not a working my grammar
wasn't the best
maybe try my name is probably a little
more prevalent on google
top top ten nico perringer dreams
top 10 list of your dreams
here's a top 10 list of all of your best
dreams nice
that's weird i like i like these
preposterous ones that don't have right
answers
one oh my god it's just blanks oh
weird yeah that was that weird that's
no no no no
no no no no no no try again
i can't imagine what [ __ ] it's spitting
out uh it's just that you're on a boat
like 10 times
let's try one more i really like the
song lyrics
that seems to work really well yeah oh
this one's
oh here we go 10.
you were a member of a swat team nine a
dream
i was in a plane crash parenthesis not a
dream i got a promotion at work
seven i was a substitute teacher six
i was in a car accident oh parenthesis
not a dream
i was a professional figure skater i was
a cop a professional boxer professional
boxer i was a clown
and then the number one top dream is the
one where you fought a dragon
um give me uh these are the hit video
games from the year 2030.
oh yeah we've compiled a list of all the
hit video games from the year 2030
which is only nine years from now yeah
crazy chrono trigger
after a hundred years of development
chrono trigger is
finally released
they've spent a century on this game no
one understood what was going on but
they liked the graphics
super mario 64. the first 3d platformer
was a
huge success it was the first game to be
marketed with a first
person mode which allowed players to
look at the world through mario's eyes
they made a separate game out of this
version called super mario 64
first-person mode
uh full house the most amazing part of
this game is that was based on a show
that was still on the air after six
years of the developments full house the
game was finally released to the general
public
the brain trainer the first nintendo wii
game to challenge your mind
batman
[Laughter]
the year 2028 saw the death of the
superhero genre
batman batman was the last superhero
game released and was widely considered
to be too violent for kids
pokemon the 2028 pokemon title finally
allowed players to play as the legendary
mewtwo
dude just calls out the death of the
superhero
casually drops that bomb oh my god it's
like those little gems that's what makes
us so
good super mario details man
a new version of the game was released
called super mario bros colon party
edition
the game soundtrack
just all over top of each other like at
the same time
dark legacy the game was originally
called dark legacy the legend of the
kingdom of darkness but the developer
changed the name because it was too
generic
panda racer the year 2030 was a big year
for the panda this game was the first
time a panda was allowed to drive a car
[Laughter]
skateboard half pipe
now that one is just simply kids were
finally allowed to get a nintendo
product that was not rated e for
everyone
oh this is so funny dude goodness
golden eye james bond was a once great
series that fell from grace with the
release of goldeneye
the 2028 game
[Laughter]
oh man
dude give me more video games i'm sorry
panda racer is one of the funniest
[ __ ] things i've ever heard yeah
the first time a car driving car
it's giving me uh i'm just gonna ask it
i'm gonna reset this and do some new
ones
oh my god this these are the best oh god
it's so funny we've compiled a list of
the most
innovative video games from the year
2031.
okay
fortnite is the most popular game in
history it's a hybrid first person
shooter and survival genre
also the first game to feature a live
server browser that means players can
see exactly which players are online in
real time
the fortnite phenomena began with a
simple premise
build a shelter and survive a meteor
shower was destroying earth so a player
needs to keep themselves safe
safe it's just describing fortnite it's
just describing fortnight now
i think your pitfall was writing
innovative
as opposed to like these are the
biggest games of 2013. the wildest what
if you say the future funniest
top 10 the funniest games from 2014 it's
the most video funniest of games from
yeah because we want funny games guys
be funny or like most revenue generating
games from 2031.
top rated games in 2031 it's just gaming
like goat simulator
goat simulator one pokemon go
this game is the same as the original
except for the fact that all the pokemon
seem to have mysterious eyes
[Laughter]
call of duty from 2031. oh
no i can't do it oh the big man came
back
baltimore came back hold on you know
just
to read it with voldemort i refreshed it
and it gave me new ones the game's the
same as the old one call of duty
except for the fact that all sounds are
replaced with the words i
and i like hey
grand theft auto the game's the same as
the old one except for the fact that the
police are replaced with one
really big hand it's just
it's doing the same format one really
big
hand
bird simulator the game's the same as
the old one but whatever you do don't
press the pause button
okay i'm so curious
what happened yeah here we go let's give
it a new mario kart
the objective of the game is to collect
fake coins as you drive around
it's doing the same cadence this game's
the same as the old one except
anyways let's take it to the uh just
these are the best games to buy your
kids
for in the year 2030 christmas
or these are the best multiplayer games
of the year that's christmas gifts for
kids
20 30 20 best christmas gifts
these are the best kid-friendly gifts
for christmas in the year 2030. in the
year
2030.
all right
no yeah it's like image credit amazon
wobble it's like clearly
reading some give me give me like uh the
plot synopsis for the uh upcoming marvel
film well here we go
one more i got this we got this we're
gonna get this
it takes a second don't forget to follow
me check out my awesome youtube channel
oh my god seriously yeah two in one
robot kit this kit is a two in one kit
it transforms a toy robot into a real
robot
it comes with a robot kit and the
programming kit the robot kit is a
do-it-yourself robot kit that allows
kids to build a robot
and program it that sounds awesome
yeah sounds pretty sick gopro hero5
gopro is a camera small lightweight
waterproof camera captures photos and
videos
camera comes with a live why don't this
is just like fast
description this is go pro fast amazon
all right wait no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no here let's see
let's do a movie synopsis uh
give me the like the plot synopsis to
the upcoming
marvel film avengers for
colin uh now it's just going to rehash
plot points
let's just see what happens all right
okay how about this one let's do uh
we should we should say we should we
need to give it one of those prompts
though like
but this time it's sent set in hell
fans are overjoyed to hear that star
wars is being rebooted
the new plotline takes some twists and
turns
fans are excited not vans are excited
stupid fans are excited to hear the new
star wars
is finally being rebooted period this
time
star wars takes place on earth
and a galaxy not so far away
fans are excited to hear about the new
star wars which is finally being
rebooted this time star wars takes place
on earth and in space
the movie is called star wars episode 7
the fallen jedi order
the fallen jedi order will be about the
time when there was a bunch of jedi
knights running around on earth and in
space they all died and were replaced
with the new jedi order
three boots great for fans who were
distraught about the original star wars
release because
it was getting a bit old
[Laughter]
and it would be great news for the star
wars franchise because it will allow
disney to make a huge profit just like
they did with the avengers
[Laughter]
gotta give you a plot synopsis gotta
push it towards that direction
what happens in the new film the new
movie will be released in 2015 is
written by jj abrams
plot synopsis
might delete the jj abrams 2015 ruby
will tell of a time when the jedi
knights control the earth and the space
in between them
how the jedi knights were wiped out by a
bunch of people with big sticks
and a lot of anger it will also tell the
story about how all these people will
stick somehow manage to
become jedi knights themselves you'll
also tell the story of a man who tried
to save them all he'll also tell the
story of a man who brought back the dark
side of the force
um luke skywalker has been replaced by
uh yep one second
we should do this on a live stream yeah
this would be hilarious if we could
have people suggest stuff right
yeah this is like the best what if game
skywalker has been replaced with a hot
young actor
here's a photo of the new luke skywalker
named luke davenport
luke davenport people are excited about
the new star wars and they're especially
excited about the new cast
because they're really hot
luke skywalker because he looks like a
young harrison ford
[Laughter]
which means oh because he's so hot and
because he's only 17.
wait wait
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my god no no
bad 18 plus
all right all right all right all right
all right all right that's enough
i gotta bounce here guys uh yeah that
was that was great
oh my god if i wasn't using an ipad this
would be a lot easier uh
it wasn't too bad song lyric give me one
more song oh yeah
all right oh the best song to sing when
ending a podcast no i got this
next the best song to sing here are the
lyrics
to our outro theme for our podcast
comma
called corridor
cast all right here we go
[Music]
i'm waiting on him i know hold on
trying to select them
[Music]
all right jake we got the lyrics inbound
i'm so ready for this okay
it was a beautiful night the stars are
out now
the moon is bright we're all alone we're
all alone now
the sky has opened up
the moon is full and stars they shine
bright
the moon has shown us the way
that's it that's it it wasn't as good as
the canadian if i was canadian i'd be in
canada
i'd have better healthcare and get to
keep my guns
okay till next time all right yep
wow thanks for watching everybody look
towards the moon yeah thanks for
listening
oh hey there's a sweet video coming out
on sunday
oh yeah attacking titans come out this
sunday oh yeah it's spicy spicy deal of
attack and titan
all right my eyes i've been crying
thanks for listening oh god that was
funny